[Musique]
bienvenue dans auditions publiques sur
LCP Public Sénat jusqu'à 20h30 et de 10
demain 10e manifestation contre la
réforme des retraites deux questions
s'imposent à ce stade sera-t-elle aussi
massive que toutes les précédentes et
puis les violences seront-elles évitées
les services d'or des syndicats et la
police vont-elles contenir les
débordements redoutés face à cette
contestation sociale impressionnante le
président campe sur la fermeté bonjour
bonsoir plutôt Olivier Faure merci
d'être avec nous dans auditions
publiques patrons du PS qui a signé
l'accord législatif avec LFI où est la
sortie Olivier Feurs
on va dire qui emmenait le mouvement
vers la nups où et la sortie de cette
crise nous sommes impatients de de vous
entendre demandez-vous comme Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et Marine Le Pen le départ
d'Elizabeth borne sa promesse par
exemple de ne plus recourir en 49-3 hors
budget
est-elle un geste d'apaisement au
Parlement Brigitte boucher tamtrane dans
quelques instants sur la montée des
violences entre autres Yves réa sur
l'avenir de la nups Vincent roux vous
soumettra deux questions d'actualité et
puis merci d'avoir accepté le principe
du débat face à vous tout à l'heure le
sénateur Renaissance Xavier yakovelli je
voudrais d'abord avoir un commentaire de
votre part sur les dernières
déclarations des manuels Macron qui
recevait à l'Elysée les responsables de
la majorité et les ténor du gouvernement
il a déclaré je cite qu'il veut
continuer continuer à tendre la main au
syndicat c'est un geste d'apaisement du
Président
je vois bien ce que c'est de faire
changer de séquence laisser penser que
tout ça est derrière nous que la
retraite c'est fini et qu'on passe à
autre chose la difficulté c'est que
personne ne le souhaite et que nous
allons continuer les uns et les autres à
marquer le terrain et à continuer à
exiger le retrait de cette réforme et
donc je vois bien les efforts
démesuré qu'il utilise aujourd'hui
en fait il n'a pas compris que en
réalité il a des gens en face à lui qui
sont déterminés et qui sont soutenus par
l'essentiel de la population française
une immense majorité de la population
française et contre cette réforme et
donc quel serait les raisons que nous
n'aurions nous de continuer à céder à
celui qui continuait à se prendre pour
Jupiter parce que c'est bien là le
problème c'est qu'on a un président qui
part orgueil refuse de retirer ce projet
mais en fait
quel intérêt général alors qu'on sait
très bien que les travaux du corps nous
disent que il n'y a rien qui soit
insoluble que nous ne sommes pas au bord
de la faillite que cette question là
pour être soldée complètement
différemment contrairement à ce qu'il a
pu dire il existe d'autres alternatives
qui n'ont pas été envisagées par le
gouvernement mais qui existe sur
lesquels on pourrait revenir et donc
matière là à côté station et donc quand
tu es français lui disent non c'est non
alors si le Conseil constitutionnel ça
c'est une question importante parce que
il va se prononcer il y a plusieurs
recours sur la validité de la voix la
loi si le Conseil constitutionnel valide
la réforme dans trois semaines est-ce
que vous vous continuez la contestation
mais vous avez quelques souvenirs quand
même de ce qui s'est passé pour le CPE
le CPE avait été non seulement adopté
par le 49-3 il avait ensuite fait
l'objet d'une validation par le Conseil
constitutionnel même été promulguée et
Jacques Chirac avait ensuite demandé à
ses ministres de ne pas l'appliquer et
bien je pense que c'est la même chose
qui va s'appliquer aujourd'hui et il
faut évidemment
pas le dernier mot pour vous
entendent que vous vous contestez la
légitimité de la de la loi de la réforme
seulement
vous dire que ce qui est fait illégal le
49-3 est constitutionnel déjà parce
qu'il est constitutionnel qu'il est
légitime de l'employé et qu'il légitime
de considérer que cette réforme est
approuvée par le peuple français je vois
au contraire des gens qui chaque jour
plus nombreux et nous sommes sur
l'antenne de LCP et Public Sénat et donc
vous aviez un sondage qui vient de
sortir aujourd'hui et qui dit que ça
progresse encore que plus le temps passe
et plus les Français sont hostiles à
cette réforme
écoutez encore une phrase d'Emmanuel
Macron prononcée aujourd'hui devant les
leaders de la majorité il y a un réel
projet politique mené par la France
insoumise c'est pas votre partie qui
tente de délégitimer l'ordre raisonnable
nos institutions ils pensent au Conseil
constitutionnel il accuse elle est fille
de vouloir délégitimer le Conseil
constitutionnel par la contestation que
le parti fera la validation vous l'avez
rappelé je ne suis pas à leurs insoumise
mais ce que je sais et qui est quand
même l'évidence c'est qu'ils ont signé
le recours devant le Conseil
constitutionnel donc c'est bien la
preuve qui est inscrit dans les
institutions de la République et qu'ils
sont une décision qui n'ira pas dans le
sens dans le sens que veut Jean-Luc
Mélenchon alors même y compris ce que
les gens n'ont pas encore dit
on continuera de contester c'est ce que
vous dites aussi ce n'est pas de
contester la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel Conseil constitutionnel
agira en droit et il dira si ce projet
était conforme à la Constitution ça
c'est une chose moi c'est un sujet qui
est un sujet à part c'est un sujet
parallèle et puis alors évidemment si le
Conseil invalide la question est soldée
et donc c'est une sortie de crise mais
si le Conseil n'invalide pas ça ne veut
pas dire pour autant que politiquement
il est justifié et ce que nous défendons
tous ensemble avec l'ensemble des
parties de gauche l'Inter syndicales qui
est pour une fois complètement rassemblé
et uni c'est que nous sommes toutes et
tous convaincus que ce projet n'a pas de
légitimité parce qu'il est désapprouvé
par l'ensemble des Français deux
questions et puis ensuite
brigitte est un viendront nous rejoindre
s'il vous invite à l'Élysée manuel
Macron Cindy au parti qui conteste dans
la rue la réforme venez discuter avec
moi est-ce que vous y allez
tout dépend pourquoi faire en fait je me
suis rendu à son invitation au mois de
juin après l'élection législative je lui
ai dit ce que je pensais de ce que la
façon dont on devait conduire les
affaires du pays puisque il y avait une
majorité relative et donc dans un
trillions dans une période de
parlementaire sous les ponts depuis
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui si vous dit
écoutez on se met tout sur la table on
essaye de on essaye aujourd'hui de
trouver une solution sans vous y allez
ou pas ça dépend de ce qu'il est facile
commence par à le préalable qui le
retrait du projet et qu'il dit je remets
tout à plat et je suis prêt à avancer
avec l'ensemble des forces qui composent
le Parlement dans ces cas-là on peut se
parler mais encore faut-il qu'il écoute
je vais continuer à faire ce que je veux
mais je voudrais votre accord la réponse
elle est déjà claire c'est pas d'accord
pour faire ce qu'il veut Emmanuel Macron
rien ne va le faire céder aujourd'hui
rien ne peut le faire céder pardon pour
l'instant si aujourd'hui je vous dis ça
le lundi 27 mars est-ce que vous allez
passer est-ce que vous allez passer à
des combats que vous pouvez gagner
mais je crois que ce combat là nous
pouvons le gagner et que nous devons le
gagner et que nous le devons aux
Français il n'y a aucune raison de
penser que
rappelez-vous de Villepin quand 15 jours
avant que Jacques Chirac ne prenne la
décision forçage qu'il prie à l'époque
annonçait partout que jamais rien ne les
ferait reculer et puis ils ont reculé
Brigitte boucher tomtranuit se sentait
en phase de vous et elles vont
maintenant vous poser des questions
nombreuses évidemment Brigitte Tam oui
une dixième journée de manifestation et
donc prévue demain pour protester contre
la réforme des retraites lors de la
dernière il y a eu un regain de
mobilisation qu'est-ce que vous attendez
de celle-ci est-ce que vous êtes
confiant dans la mobilisation de demain
oui je suis confiant dans cette
mobilisation parce que je vois que
autour de moi les gens continuent à être
très mobilisés et très en colère avec un
pouvoir qui n'écoute rien et donc il y a
maintenant non seulement la contestation
de la réforme mais aussi la conversation
de la méthode employée par le
gouvernement et de 49-3 le 44 3 le 44.2
l'article 38 du Règlement etc il y a une
espèce d'addition qui fait même dire à
des gens j'ai lu le professeur Rousseau
qui n'est pas forcément
qui n'est pas qui n'est pas membre de la
nups et qui n'est pas praticiste non
plus et qui pour autant considère que il
y a toutes les raisons aujourd'hui
d'invalider un projet qui a été
adopté dans des conditions qui sont
absolument
insincert et qui sont une brutalisation
du Parlement donc oui je crois que il y
a aujourd'hui la nature à se révoltée et
ce que font les gens dans la rue semaine
après semaine oui je serai comme depuis
depuis 10 fois depuis 10 fois alors vous
parlez de cette colère il y aussi eu des
violences notamment depuis le 49-3 la
semaine dernière plus de 1000 casseurs
est-ce que vous faites confiance au
syndicats et à la police pour que demain
ça ne se réalise pas je fais confiance à
la raison de celles et ceux qui ont
intérêt que ça se passe bien et vous
l'aurez noté pendant des mois et des
mois il y a eu des manifestations qui se
sont passées dans un ordre absolument
irréproché de nature ça a changé de
nature mais alors pour quelle raison
se faisaient et moi j'avais salué y
compris la façon dont les choses avaient
changé au moment où on est passé de
Didier l'allemand à le rendre Lunel
nouveau préfet de police de Paris on a
pas rechangé depuis en revanche le mode
de maintien de l'ordre lui a changé on
voit débarquer les bras même la BAC etc
et qui eux ont des méthodes de maintien
de l'ordre si on peut appeler ça du
maintien de l'ordre
aujourd'hui des jeunes principalement
qui brûlent des poubelles ça ne suppose
pas en réponse que vous ayez des gens
qui partent à l'hôpital qui soient
de Black Box Black Bloc mélangé là jeudi
dernier c'était des gentils étudiants
qui brûlaient des poubelles il y a
certainement des blagues blocs qui se
mêlent aux manifestations
que je sais c'est que ça existe mais ça
ne suppose pas de taper dans le tas si
vous voyez ce que je veux dire parce que
le problème aujourd'hui c'est que vous
avez des gens qui sont là pour
manifester qui sont absolument non
violents et qui se retrouvent en garde à
vue et je pourrais vous donner des
témoignages nombreux ils ont d'ailleurs
la répression policière aujourd'hui en
France il y a un problème de doctrine
humans et que il y a aujourd'hui il y a
sa supposerait de le vérifier sous les
ordres de qui est-ce que c'est
simplement les bras même ou là-bas que
qui de leur plein gré et sans aucun
commandement se mettent à taper en le
temps ou est-ce que on a au contraire
une allusion assez claire quand même au
fait
je pense que il y a aujourd'hui la
volonté de mettre face à face l'ordre et
le chaos et le chaos serait incarné par
les manifestants et l'ordre par le
pouvoir en place
c'est-à-dire qu'on organise le chaos
pour pouvoir représenter
ça vient aujourd'hui vous avez quand
même enfin vous avez des nasses qui sont
revenus alors qu'on en avait plus on en
avait plus vous avez des centaines de
jeunes qui sont arrêtés alors même
qu'ils n'ont rien à se reprocher vous
avez des tabassages en règle vous avez
quand même des images aujourd'hui qui
documentent ce que je dis je ne suis pas
en inventer une histoire vous avez des
gens qui se font rouler dessus par les
motos vous avez des gens qui se font
insulter menacés par les policiers des
policiers qui craquent après avoir été
insultés dans ses dépenses
quelques individus vous dites ça n'est
pas ça c'est un système
ça effectivement on pourrait tous
craquer mais enfin moi je connais c'est
quand même de la violence du côté des
manifestants ou pas Olivier fort vous
connaissez quand même de la violence du
côté des manifestants il y a toujours
mais on pourrait parler aussi des des
super bassines etc des méga bassines on
va y aller mais c'est pas je ne mélange
pas les gens qui sont venus qui sont des
activistes et qui sont là pour justement
s'en prendre en force de l'ordre et au
bien public etc et que je réouvre
complètement et que je condamne et puis
ceux qui sont là pour manifester et qui
malheureusement sont pris à partir alors
qu'ils ne sont pour rien
de sens solides
ils n'arrivent que quand ils ont le
sentiment qu'ils sont à ce moment-là
dans une situation où ils peuvent
s'affronter aux forces ils n'ont pas
fait pendant deux mois
afin de Soline on a les gendarmes et les
manifestants qui aujourd'hui se
rejettent chacun la responsabilité des
violences dans les manifestations vous
vous situez de quel côté parce que là on
voit vraiment l'affrontement des thèses
moi je sais pas mais je vais vous dire
une chose toute simple si j'étais en
responsabilité à l'intérieur et qu'on me
disait qu'il y a chiffre de la police
puisque c'est pas les mêmes que ceux des
manifestants les manifestations disent
30 000 participants la police dit 6000
moi je ne mettrai pas 3000 policiers en
face déjà vous rendez compte qu'il y
avait un policier pour deux manifestants
vous en metriez combien
ça s'est passé
qui viennent au milieu de la pampa qui
sont en train de d'avancer avec leur
drapeau qui viennent manifester aux
animaux
boule de pétanque vous croyez qu'ils
allaient les utiliser contre qui il y a
pas de policiers en fait vous avez des
gens
Olivier fort donc c'est normal que les
autorités publiques dans un trou comme
ça parce que des champs
d'occuper le terrain
occuper le site
c'est un bocage vous avez des fermes au
milieu vous avez des gens qui sur place
sont soutenez les manifestations etc
vous êtes au milieu de rien vous êtes
dans des champs sur la culture intensive
et vous avez absolument besoin
de venir avec des boules de béton pour
une manifestation interdite et qu'en
plus il y a des élus
des matraques tout ce que vous voulez
tout ça me paraît complètement hors de
enfin je condamne complètement ce genre
d'activisme mais si justement je sais
qu'il y a des activistes qui cherchent
en découdre je ne donne pas les moyens
d'en découdre
sur le champ ils auraient envahi
l'immense trou parce qu'il n'y a rien à
défendre en réalité en l'occurrence il y
a pas de bassines pour l'instant vous
avez une excavation de terre point barre
donc le sujet il est pas là par contre
il y a un sujet qui ferait aussi aborder
le sujet de fond c'est pourquoi on
déploie 3000 policiers pour interdire
une manifestation alors que vous avez
des projets qui ont été jugés illégaux
par la justice et que là ces projets
continuent à être en activité et que là
il y a pas un accord il y avait une
influence radio c'est pas la première
manière
aujourd'hui elles sont toujours en usage
parce que personne n'intervient si la
force doit rester au droit ça va être le
droit partout et y compris quand la
justice tranche et bien il faut en fait
faire appliquer la loi c'était normal
que des députés viennent manifester
alors que c'était interdit sur ce site
de sainte Soline où on savait qu'il y
aurait de la violence ils sont venus de
ce que je vois de ce que j'ai compris
ils sont venus pour protéger les blessés
pour dire que il fallait s'interposer un
moment et c'est quand même complètement
fou d'ailleurs qu'ils étaient eux-mêmes
pris à partie vous avez des gens qui
sont clairement identifiés avec leur
écharpe de parlementaire sur lesquels on
tire 6000 grenades qu'à 4000 grenades de
désinstallement pour 6000 manifestants
d'ailleurs vous trouverez pas la
personne enfin est-ce que vous êtes
normales
le Conseil de l'Europe la Ligue des
droits de l'homme
tout le monde aujourd'hui demande à ce
qu'il y a une forme de proportionnalité
qui soit conservée c'est ça quand même
le problème aujourd'hui
d'encourager cette violence la macronie
elle accuse la nupesse de ces violences
à Sainte Soline Gérald Darmanin dénonce
une bordélisation voulue par une partie
de l'extrême gauche de l'ultra gauche
est-ce que le but c'est effectivement de
tout bordaliser pour pour que cette
réforme soit retirée je viens de vous
répondre sur le fait que on peut très
bien enfin la face le désordre c'est
quoi c'est l'injustice créé par ce de
loin donc aujourd'hui si vous voulez en
finir et que les ordres il faut remettre
de l'ordre et l'ordre social d'abord et
c'est comme ça que vous aurez le reste
et c'est pas en
continuant à dire je suis Jupiter je
fais face au peuple français qui dans
son immense majorité n'est pas d'accord
avec moi mais parce que je suis le chef
je maintiens après de là vous avez
toutes les conditions pour arriver
effectivement à ce qui est différente et
Sandrine Rousseau n'ont pas condamné
tout de suite ces violences quand même
ils ont mis du temps avant de le faire
est-ce que vous trouvez ça normal est-ce
qu'il fallait pas le faire un peu plus
tôt ce qu'il y a des circonstances
atténuantes à ces casseurs dans une
partie de la nuque non mais moi j'avais
pas de je crois pas que quiconque prône
la violence au sein de la nuque c'est
même tout l'inverse nous sommes tous
pour que c'est les choses se passent en
bon ordre et je ne suis pas comptable de
l'horaire auquel Jean-Luc Mélenchon
Sandrine Rousseau prenne position moi je
vous dis le chose très clairement je
vous dis il n'est pas la violence n'est
pas tolérable en démocratie qu'elle
vienne des manifestants ou qu'elle
vienne du pouvoir en place
maintenant le problème c'est que il faut
aussi ne pas générer soi-même les
conditions qui conduisent à la violence
vous avez parlé tout à l'heure des bras
même des enregistrements ont été
dévoilés par le monde loopsiders qui
mettent en cause c'est brigade motorisé
Laurent Nunez demande une enquête de
l'IGPN est-ce que c'est suffisant pour
est-ce qu'il faut les dissoudre pour
vous moi d'abord je souhaiterais que on
en finisse avec la question de l'IGPN
c'est-à-dire que il faut qu'à un moment
enfin plus exactement qu'on en fasse un
organe de contrôle qui soit complètement
indépendant c'est une demande qui est
récurrente ça fait longtemps là moi
j'aimerais que le GPN soit vraiment un
organe indépendant pour pas mettre aussi
que les jugements les constatations
l'instruction qui sont réalisées par
l'IGPN soit incontestable aujourd'hui
parce que aujourd'hui vous avez toujours
un doute qui existe quand vous êtes
juges et partis forcément il y a un
doute qui existe
comme certains demandent un organe de
contrôle totalement indépendant et
ensuite il faudrait effectivement au
moins une commission d'enquête
parlementaire qui permet d'aller
elle est arrivée aussi après le recours
aux 49-3 est-ce que vous vous souhaitez
la suppression de cet article de la
Constitution
oui je pense que ce serait en fait une
bonne manière que vous vous souvenez que
à d'autres époques Lionel Jospin avait
par exemple renoncé utiliser le 49-3
donc il faut
il avait une majorité qui était une
majorité plurielle à l'époque ça veut
dire qu'il fallait être négocier que les
uns et les autres et il le fit et cette
heureux que des gens qui sont dans une
situation où ils n'ont pas seul la
majorité cherche à en trouver une et si
on devait prendre un modèle sur nos
voisins en Europe qui n'ont pas de 49-3
comment font-ils construisent des
coalitions
politiques de notre pays serait
compliqué ici parce que ici on utilise
49 mois je préférais avec le
gouvernement vous avez stoppé sur un
seul texte les énergies renouvelables le
reste ça reste très compliqué ça dépend
de ce qu'on fait en fait on peut pas
cela pour l'instant ce qu'on est en
train de vivre c'est que le gouvernement
arrive avec son projet et dit ça à
prendre ou à laisser donc parfois on est
d'accord avec lui donc on vote pour on
n'est pas complètement
c'est apprendre ou à laisser la première
voiture elle a beaucoup évolué il est
déjà il est passé à 75 ans
[Musique]
sur les retraites puisque vous vous
souvenez du débat sur l'âge pivot 74 ans
donc il y avait déjà la CFDT y compris
qu'il y avait qui refusait la cheville
là on nous remet 74 ans nous dit ah
c'est bizarre vous n'êtes pas d'accord
mais non on a toujours dit qu'on était
pas d'accord on a proposé d'autres
solutions
d'économies uniquement sur les femmes et
sur les gens qu'on consacra travailler
tôt et sur les carrières pénibles pardon
mais enfin c'est pas tout à fait un
projet juste donc là il y a un problème
s'il avait au contraire dit ben écoutez
moi je souhaite qu'on puisse regarder
quels sont les modes de financement
possible comment est-ce qu'on peut
retrouver ces 12 milliards dont on a
besoin bah on aurait dit pourquoi pas on
regarde mais là
on vous entendez pas crier au déni de
démocratie à l'époque pardon mais enfin
si vous vous souvenez bien à l'époque
j'avais moi demander à ce qu'on
n'utilise pas le 49-3 même si ensuite je
l'ai accepté parce que j'étais en la
majorité et que je n'ai pas eu le choix
mais j'avais demandé à ce qu'on revienne
sur la loi travail sur un nombre
d'articles et j'avais trouvé un
compromis avec les frondeurs de l'époque
avec france ouvrière avec un certain
nombre de gens dans le monde syndical et
dans la gauche de l'époque
malheureusement au moment où cet accord
a été trouvé
au moment où je l'ai présenté Manuel
Valls m'avait opposé le 49.3
effectivement vous croyez qu'elle n'aura
pas à utiliser
vous la croyez vous pensez que je la
crois d'autant moins qu'elle dit je ne
l'utiliserai plus comme matière
budgétaire mais sauf que ça fait 11 49
fois qu'elle vient d'utiliser les 11
étaient en matière budgétaires donc en
gros elle nous dit en fait je ferai
comme je fais depuis toujours
les un mot
budgétaires c'est le 47 1 sur
la réforme un mot pardon sur les
violences sur les élus vous avez dit
votre soutien Aurore berger qui a été
menacé par une lettre ainsi que son bébé
de 4 mois il y a eu aussi la présidente
de l'Assemblée nationale votre votre
réaction face à ce phénomène qui
s'aggrave et faut-il du coup aussi
aggraver les sanctions
en colère qui savent pas comment
l'exprimer qui sont souvent un peu
désoeuvrés et puis regarder
tout de suite dès que j'ai déçu je l'ai
condamné mais il faut voir moi je ne
sais pas qui est cette personne qui a
écrit enfin quand je vois son écriture
je me dis que peut-être qu'on a pas à
faire à quelqu'un qui est complètement
complètement à l'aise dans la vie donc
soyons raisonnables 10 ans de prison
c'est pas mal non d'accord est-ce que il
y a une part de responsabilité du débat
parlementaire par exemple quand un
député elle est fi en l'occurrence à
traiter un ministre d'assassin ce qu'il
a pas fourni aussi le carburant à cette
violence que l'on voit
on a eu beaucoup de débats là
mais il y a eu tout un climat violence
etc de la part des élus franchement je
me souviens quand même face à fait
quelques années quand même que je
regarde où que je vis au cœur de
l'hémicycle ce qui se passe à
l'Assemblée assassin c'est un terme qui
a été utilisé 152 fois en fait y compris
il a été utilisé pour faire quelque
chose
du débat politique
de la durée d'allongement en fait moi
j'étais traité d'assassin aussi par
courrier pour le coup par des gens qui
peut-être assassins parce qu'on a langé
la durée de recours
vous voyez bien de quoi on parle à
partir du moment où un début de la
République très terminée est-ce que ça
n'est pas en creux ou directement
et est-ce que c'est et alors je ne dis
pas que c'est bien je l'ai connu
parce que là c'est nous-même donnons un
écho à ce qui a été en fait un dérapage
qui a été immédiatement la personne
c'est immédiatement excusée et donc on
en fait beaucoup pour un truc qui
la semaine dernière le projet de loi
nucléaire a été adopté à une large
majorité finalement il y a un désaccord
sur les retraites mais sinon
l'assemblée continue de légiférer le
gouvernement gouverne
bah oui le gouvernement gouverne il y a
des désaccords et des points d'accord
c'est vrai il y a pas de que vous pouvez
vous je vous dise par rapport à ça
l'immobilier
parce qu'il y a 20 textes qui ont été
adoptés depuis le début de la
législature en fait il n'y a pas de
volonté de passer en force ça se passe
pas si mal donc voilà pour les entrées
quand vous faites pas de bêtises ça se
passe bien donc continuez donc qu'il
continue à faire passer les textes moi
je n'ai pas de problème avec la
démocratie quand je n'ai pas voté le
texte sur le nucléaire pour des raisons
qui sont liées à la fusion de l'IRSN et
de la scène
en rapport non non il y a un rapport qui
est sur l'opportunité ce qui passe sur
l'opportunité mais sur les conditions
dans laquelle ta sœur se réaliser donc
il y a bien le projet maintenu du
gouvernement de faire en sorte que celui
qui prend la décision doit être sûr de
tes nucléaire soit aussi celle qui
intègre les services de ceux qui sont à
l'origine des recherches donc il y a un
problème là de juger donc je ne l'ai pas
voté mais ça a été voté c'est
incontestable je ne vais pas maintenant
dire
maintenant avec le gouvernement comme
vous l'avez fait sur le renouvelable
enfin la fin des retraites ne met pas un
point un coup d'arrêt à tout ça il y a
un sujet il va falloir qu'on en parle
les uns et les autres pour voir comment
est-ce qu'on réagit pour ne pas faire
comme si cet épisode as du joual parce
que c'est pas possible sur tous les
autres textes si je comprends bien parce
que je ne sais pas il y a des textes qui
méritent malgré tout un soutien etc
cette semaine il y a le texte de mon ami
et camarade Arthur de Laporte sur les
influenceurs qui va être adopté c'est
très bien donc je ne veux pas être
catégorie mais heureusement
merci beaucoup Brigitte merci Tom et en
soin on retrouve tout de suite Vincent
roux en direct du Figaro live mon cher
Vincent la première question d'actualité
que vous soumettez à Olivier Faure
bonsoir Elizabeth bonsoir Olivier fort
bien précisément c'est sur les textes
qui restent encore à voter il y en avait
un qui était prévu juste après la
réforme des retraites c'était le projet
de loi sur l'immigration le gouvernement
Emmanuel Macron a annoncé son report il
a il a eu raison
moi je je ne sais pas exactement
je vois ce qui s'est passé au Sénat et
que on a réussi à avoir un amendement
voté largement sur le renoncement à
l'aide médicale d'État je suis inquiet
en fait vous avez aujourd'hui cette aide
médicale d'État qu'on se comprenne bien
c'est la possibilité pour des gens y
compris qui n'ont pas de papier de
pouvoir se faire soigner pourquoi est-ce
qu'on fait ça parce que c'est bien pire
médical d'État oui mais enfin les
épidémies aussi et donc qu'est-ce que
vous préférez vous préférez moi je
préfère en fait que mes enfants soient
en sécurité parce qu'on prend en charge
des gens qui peuvent être propagateur de
maladies infectieuses plutôt que de les
voir traîner et d'avoir demain une
maladie qui se répand partout et puis
parce qu'il y a quelque chose qui
devrait quand même tous nous intéresser
c'est l'humanité et donc moi pour moi
une personne migrante ça n'est pas une
plante ou un animal c'est un être humain
qui mérite le respect et qui mérite
aussi les soins ça s'appelle un
assistant cette personne autrement
est-ce que il faut que le gouvernement
renonce à sa loi immigration et en
particulier la partie consistant à
simplifier la possibilité de d'expulser
réellement les
occupés les occutaires les obligations
de quitter le territoire français ou
bien est-ce qu'il faut laisser les
choses dans l'état d'abord la question
là je paye pas pendant 15 secondes la
réalité est bien pourtant
la difficulté elle ne tient pas à une
loi française elle tient au laisser
passer consulaire et donc au rapport
qu'on entretien avec les pays d'origine
et par ailleurs la question migratoire
n'est pas se prendre exclusivement
réduire le nombre de recours
oui bah je suis pas pour la réduction du
nombre de recours quand les recours sont
justifiés il faut qu'ils puissent avoir
lieu et par ailleurs je souhaite qu'on
prenne cette question là au plan
européen parce que c'est une question
européenne qu'on revienne sur la
question de Dublin qu'on revienne sur un
certain nombre de sujets qui font que et
qu'on ouvre des voies aussi migratoires
légales qui permettent d'avoir donc à
côté des gens que l'on doit refouler à
nos frontières parce qu'ils n'ont pas de
raison de venir chez nous qu'on ouvre
aussi d'autres voies qui soient en
dehors de la question de du droit
d'asile en dehors du regroupement
familial ou de des études mais qu'on
puisse avoir une voix humanitaire qu'on
puisse avoir une voix climatique pas
être aussi à des gens qui sont en danger
aujourd'hui de pouvoir trouver
assistance chez nous je voudrais qu'on
ait la même intentionnalité aussi bien
pour les Ukrainiens que pour les Afghans
ce serait bien que on n'est pas de poids
de mesure non plus merci beaucoup
Vincent à tout à l'heure Yves très aussi
en face de vous directeur adjoint du
Figaro bonjour bonsoir Elisabeth bonsoir
alors l'avenir de la gauche
je voudrais qu'on en parle de la dupez
du Parti socialiste alors il y a un cas
concret très précis qui nous permet de
de rentrer dans ce sujet c'est une
élection partielle législative partielle
qui a lieu dimanche prochain dans
l'Ariège donc dans le midi de la France
dans le sud de la France qui oppose un
représentant de la France insoumise
madame
Bénédicte taurine qui est arrivé en tête
au premier tour contre et bien une une
militante du Parti socialiste madame
Martine Froget qui est arrivé 7 8 points
derrière elle pour qui allez vous donner
la consigne de votre bon je vous
reconnais bien là
mais si si parce que ce sont les fait
c'est que je vais les préciser c'est que
la candidat de Bénédicte taurine est
soutenue par l'ensemble des parties de
gauche Parti socialiste compris et en
face d'elle elle a en fait une
socialiste dissidente ce n'est pas une
partie socialiste qui a envoyé cette
candidate là certes donc
et la décision elle est très claire
c'est que nous soutenons la candidate de
la nouvelle union populaire tout
simplement parce que cette élection est
une réplique de l'élection législative
de juin et que donc nous avons passé un
accord engin et que moi je tiens à notre
signature si demain matin j'explique que
au fond je signe des accords mais que je
ne les respecte pas qui signera encore
avec moi donc je ne veux pas signer
n'importe quoi n'importe comment il y en
a qui a été signé on le respecte et par
ailleurs je ne vois pas très bien
aujourd'hui ce que je alors elle était
dissidente j'étais contre sa dissidence
mais maintenant au deuxième tour au
deuxième tour il y a une candidate de la
nupes ont soutenu par les écologistes
les communistes les instruments
qui lui sont complètement étrangères
sortant même deux fois est-ce qu'elle
était élu en 2017 et 2022 donc par qui
voulez-vous faire arbitrer le duel entre
deux femmes qui se disent de gauche mais
ça va être arbitré par qui par
Renaissance par les républicains
professionnels la majorité la majorité
présidentielle qui appelle à voter
justement
et c'est quand même et vous trouvez
normal que ce soit en fait alors
Renaissance qui choisissent en fait la
gauche qu'elle veut j'écoute des
opposants j'écoute des milices des
militants ariégeois qui sont dans cette
circonscription et qui disent c'est
absolument
ubuesque parce que on va aller on nous
demande de voter pour une candidate qui
appartient à la France insoumise alors
que sa concurrente et socialiste et
c'est vrai que si vous regardez ça de
près ou de loin ça paraît quand même
incroyable de se dire que et bien vous
êtes prêt finalement à lâcher quelqu'un
qui
est un compagnon de route pour vous
bonne mémoire pour ne pas vous souvenir
y compris de ce que furent le RPR et
l'UDF
il y avait une circonscription qui était
donnée à l'UDF bah les gens du RPA
n'était pas candidat dessus c'est aussi
simple que ça et donc si vous voulez des
coalitions on en a parlé beaucoup quoi
que ce soit mais ça suppose des accords
et pour avoir des accords et ça suppose
de respecter le fait qu'à tel endroit
c'est quelqu'un d'un parti a-t-elle
entre des gens d'un autre parti voilà
autrement vous n'avez plus de coalition
si vous dites en fait quand je suis
socialiste je vois toujours pour le
social socialiste mais vous avez plus un
accord avec personne ni avec les
communistes ni que les écologistes ni
que les insoumis donc c'est c'est une
rhétorique qui est en fait qui a
l'apparence du bon sens mais qui en
réalité qu'on a à l'isolement absolu
donc c'est une erreur complète alors
vous avez trouvé un accord électoral
avec les autres compositions les autres
composantes de la gauche et il y a pas
très longtemps il y a maintenant ça va
peut-être faire bientôt un an quand même
Jean-Luc Mélenchon récemment cette
exprimé pour dire moi mon objectif c'est
toujours de faire tomber la 5e
République est-ce que c'est votre
objectif je sais pas si il a dit ça en
tout cas
la Sixième République moi je suis pour
une évolution de nos institutions
effectivement je pense que elles sont à
bout de souffle et que nous avons
aujourd'hui un vrai sujet qui est en
fait on le voit bien on est on passe de
crise en crise et on passe d'une crise
sociale à une crise politique dans
laquelle nous allons rentrer avec
l'usage du 49-3 aujourd'hui qui pourra
utiliser le 49-3 il est temps de mettre
évidemment le débat sur la table et de
faire en sorte que nos institutions
soient beaucoup plus démocratiques ça a
été le cas dans la crise des gilets
jaunes qui réclamaient un Rick le
référendum d'initiative citoyenne on a
aujourd'hui un RIP dans chacun sait
qu'il est qu'il a été
mis sur la table par Nicolas Sarkozy
mais pour qu'il ne fonctionne jamais
parce que la réforme qui la conduite
avec Édouard ballet dur en 2008
absolument et donc qui est très
compliqué à mettre en oeuvre et qui peut
être purgé bon ça dure la procédure est
dure voilà très compliqué donc on voit
bien que tout a été fait en réalité pour
tenir le peuple français à l'écart et
nous ne sommes plus en 58 nous étions
alors en pleine guerre d'Algérie nous
étions avec un pouvoir qui était fragile
après une quatrième République qui avait
montré
supprimer la fonction de Président de la
République par exemple telle qu'elle
existe aujourd'hui et bien il y a un
débats que nous devons avoir sur la
nature du pouvoir présidentiel moi par
exemple je suis partisan de transférer
le droit de dissolution du président de
la Premier ministre qui lui met et le
seul responsable devant l'assemblée
d'avoir un équilibre des pouvoirs et de
faire en sorte que le pouvoir soit
transféré en réalité vers le Premier
ministre qui lui dépend d'une coalition
et qui lui est obligé de faire des
compromis et ne plus avoir un Jupiter
qui considère que parce qu'il a été élu
une fois
pendant cinq ans
absolue ce qui n'est quand même pas
complètement démocratique vous avez
prononcé le mot le mot qui peut être
magique pour certains c'est dissolution
est-ce que la dissolution selon vous est
un moyen de sortir de la crise dans
laquelle nous sommes aujourd'hui mais
est-ce que vous la souhaitez cette
dissonance devrait avait eu les mots
justes à l'époque dans Michel Debré
pardon avait eu les mots justes à
l'époque oui c'est un des moyens de
purger une crise quand on se demande ce
que pense le peuple français bon lui
rend la parole et c'est lui qui dit
voilà la majorité que je souhaite et
donc on aurait une réponse je suis pour
je n'appelle pas à la dissolution mais
je n'en ai pas peur je considère que
j'avais dit alors au moment où 49-3
était utilisé et on a eu cette explosion
de colère dans le dans la population
française j'ai dit qu'il y a trois fois
sorti de crise possible le retrait aussi
l'orgueil du président est blessé parce
qu'il ne veut pas retirer quoi que ce
soit et bien qu'il rende la parole au
peuple français il y a deux façons de le
faire soit la dissolution soit le
référendum et toutes ces solutions là me
vont alors la dissolution je précisément
il y a un sondage qui est paru il y a
pas très longtemps qui a été réalisé par
l'Ifop et qui montre qu'en cas de
dissolution donc de nouvelles élections
législatives bah le grand gagnant c'est
le rassemblement national qui gagne 7 à
8 points et qui pourrait atterrir à
quelques 120 ou 130 députés à terme
ça ferait pas les affaires de la
majorité présidentielle pas les affaires
des républicains non plus mais pas
tellement les affaires de la gauche non
plus le grand gagnant c'est dans cette
histoire c'est quand même le
rassemblement national alors je crois
que ce soit 7 ou 8 points c'est 4 ou 5
points enfin c'est déjà trop et vous
avez raison de souligner que dans ces
sondages qui ne sont des sondages on a
l'impression que le RN pourrait
progresser beaucoup plus que les autres
bon je ne sais pas si c'est tout à fait
juste parce que je vois que dans les
parcelles ça va tout à fait ce qui se
réalise mais ce sont des partiels là
aussi c'est très particulier c'est très
particulier je suis d'accord je vous
l'accorde mais
donc il y a un danger qui ne peut pas ne
pas mesurer et c'est la raison pour
laquelle moi j'appelle y compris la
gauche à une forme de responsabilité
nous devons incarner ensemble une
capacité à gouverner demain et ça
suppose que et c'est pour ça que j'ai
proposé la semaine dernière que nous
nous acheminions progressivement vers un
nouveau contrat de coalition qui soit
négocié très tôt pour permettre
d'ailleurs aux Français de s'approprier
progressive
commun si vous voulez mais en tout cas
l'idée c'est une plateforme commune qui
vous permettent qui permettent de dire
voilà demain matin si nous devons
gouverner nous sommes prêts à le faire
et il y avait une plateforme qui avait
été signée au mois de juin mais c'est
une plateforme qui a été battue puisque
nous n'avons pas gagné de majorité donc
nous devons nous poser les bonnes
questions savoir comment nous répondons
aux inquiétudes des Français comment
nous répondons aussi à leurs colères et
comment est-ce que nous faisons pour
mieux répartir la valeur dans ce pays
comment nous faisons qu'il n'y a pas
d'alternative crédible oui enfin ça
c'est on connaît la phrase il n'y a pas
d'alternative la réponse est si Olivier
fort vous savez pourquoi parce que
a été
autre chose
il n'y a pas d'alternative il n'y avait
pas d'alternative dans le Parlement
actuel nous ne pouvons pas il n'a jamais
été question de gouverner avec l'extrême
droite donc la question c'est si nous
revenons demain dans une élection
présidentielle ou dans une élection
législative devant les Français est-ce
que nous pouvons nous la gauche incarner
l'alternative ou pas vous dites nous ne
pouvons pas je le dis avec force nous ne
pouvons pas en laisser l'exclusivité à
l'extrême droite et donc nous avons là
un enjeu majeur qui doit dominer tout le
reste qui nous permettent de nous dire
il faut qu'on soit en capacité de
gouverner les Français qui regardent la
télévision qui regardent les débats à
l'Assemblée nationale et qui voit
30 40 50 députés qui hurlent comme des
putois pendant des des minutes et des
minutes pendant le discours de la
première ministre est-ce que vous croyez
que ça leur donne envie de voter pour
ces gens-là ou au moins est-ce que ça
leur donne confiance en leur disant bah
ces gens-là sont en mesure de pouvoir
gouverner
ce sont d'ailleurs la plupart d'entre
eux je dois des vérité de le dire ne
sont pas aux parties socialistes oui
alors vous voyez si vous étiez
à chercher un peu dans l'histoire du
Parlement vous auriez vu que les
socialistes avaient eux-mêmes chanté la
Marseillaise au pied de la tribune il y
a quelques années quand Jean-Marc Ayraud
était président du groupe pour protester
juste un mouvement de solidarité c'est
un peu différent non non c'était contre
le règlement en fait le nouveau
règlement de l'Assemblée qui bridait les
rôles du Parlement mais peu importe ce
que je dis là c'est que ça franchement
ça ne va pas découragé de voter en tout
cas dans les sondages ça ne va pas
découragé de voter pour le reste enfin
rendons au folklore ce qu'il est en fait
arrêtons de toujours penser que parce
qu'il y a une chanson qui est braillée
parfois sur des tonalités pas toujours
justes et bien que ça vient complètement
à moins de rire le pouvoir du Parlement
penser que ça décourage pas les Français
de voter pour des élus qui se comportent
comme ça il faut
parlementarisme quand même je ne sais
pas sans quoi gentil parentarisme ce que
je sais c'est que il faut aussi un peu
de passion dans les va parlementaires je
sais bien qu'on veut tout à ces petits
et on voudrait que nous soyons tous des
plots qu'on soit dans un truc où
personne ne disent un mot plus haut que
l'autre mais moi j'aime bien l'idée
aussi que je n'ai pas chanté je n'ai pas
forcément approuvé le fait que on
interromptation
Jaurès ou Victor Hugo
le bouger si c'est un réel bouger on
verra et effectivement je souhaite qu'on
puisse prélever et qu'on puisse prélever
à bonne hauteur sur les super profits
parce que quand même c'est sur un profil
ne sont pas venus de du génie
particulier de qui que ce soit il y a
pas eu d'innovation de rupture il n'y a
pas eu de gain de productivité il y a
même rien en fait la seule raison pour
laquelle existe c'est qu'il y a des
super crises et qu'ils ont super
profitent voilà donc vous verrez vous
demandez à voir mais vous n'êtes pas
hostile à l'idée de mêler vos voix celle
de la majorité pour pour que les
Français puissent bénéficier de ces
dispositifs qui aident le pouvoir
d'achat
par principe je ne suis jamais hostile
par je suis pas pavloviens c'est pas
parce que c'est proposé par quelqu'un
d'autre que moi que je dis non mais ça
suppose que je vérifie et que ça aille
dans le bon sens et qu'on nous prépare
pour les andouilles non plus c'est à
dire que il faut aussi que ce soit pas
une mini imposition pour des maxi
profits ça doit être à la bonne hauteur
Xavier Iaco
aussi à vous d'avoir accepté de débattre
avec Olivier Faure qui est notre invité
ce soir auditions publiques vous êtes
sénateur renaissance des Hauts-de-Seine
vous allez peut-être vouloir revenir sur
le mouvement contre la réforme des
retraites et les manifestations oui mais
j'aimerais poser une première question
si vous le permettez à Monsieur le
Député bonjour déjà ça va bonsoir pardon
sur un sujet qui me tient
particulièrement à cœur et je pense
qu'on peut trouver une majorité de
projets sur ce sujet c'est le SLU le
service national universel depuis 2019
le président de la République avait déjà
porté en 2017 un sujet pour que les
jeunes soient les bâtisseurs d'une
nation plus fort plus juste plus
écologiste et ça pour le coup je pense
que tout le monde partage ce sujet et
puis à sa demande la Ministre en charge
justement de la jeunesse et du s&u et
Madame elaïri a porté cette mission de
généralisation voire même c'est un des
options de l'obligation du s&u avec un
séjour de cohésion de 12 jours vous
connaissez le principe 12 jours qui
s'appuie sur l'éducation nationale
l'éducation populaire et les corps en
uniforme et puis un séjour de mission
d'intérêt général sur la base du
volontariat et un autre séjour qui
pourrait être un engagement dans le
service civique depuis 2019 depuis sa
création c'est 50000 jeunes qui ont fait
qui ont pu bénéficier de ce dispositif
sur la base du volontariat dans votre
département c'est 1300 un peu plus de
1300 je crois qui ont qui en ont
bénéficié et donc je trouve que ce
projet c'est un projet structurant pour
notre nation pour notre jeunesse et donc
moi j'aimerais avoir votre opinion sur
sur la question du s&u et son obligation
surtout bon moi je suis contre
l'obligation et surtout je suis contre
un projet qui est pour l'instant très
mal ficelle et je suis pour caractère
volontaire et s'il y a des gens qui
veulent s'inscrire dans ce projet qui
est souvent qui permet de réaliser de
beaux projets avec mon associatif etc
donc ça très bien
sur l'obligation pour moi c'est un sujet
parce que surtout que là les 15 jours
qui sont proposés honnêtement on est
dans la grande improvisation avec un
coût qui va être un coup exorbitant par
rapport à ce qu'il va permettre la
cohésion en 15 jours c'est une
gigantesque blague c'est pas 15 jours
qui vont permettre le brassage social
qu'on a connu à d'autres époques avec le
service national qui est là à l'époque
était réservé aux hommes mais donc
d'accord pour envisager en fait
l'extension de ce qui existe aujourd'hui
et faire en sorte qu'il y ait plus de
jeunes qui puissent accéder au
ventariens ça a très bien mais un
service national universel où on
viendrait prendre 15 jours d'études pour
faire des séjours dans la forêt et faire
de lacrobranche franchement je suis pas
sûr que ce soit très utile c'est quoi
valeur de la République c'est pas
forcément des de l'accrobranche je pense
que vous êtes attaché comme nous aux
valeurs de la République au gestes de
premiers secours de créer de formater un
peu des citoyens de demain moi je trouve
qu'au contraire c'est très bien ben oui
donc
ne rédigez pas seulement à des parcours
dans la forêt et de l'accrobranche on
parle de plusieurs milliards pour le SNU
alors qu'on cherche des milliards pour
la sécu en fait et là je me dis en fait
on va inventer un truc qui va servir à
pas grand chose pour alors qu'on nous
explique que il nous faut trouver les
2019 non mais là je parle voté je parle
du SNU qui est envisagé par le
gouvernement et qui lui serait non pas
sur la base du volontariat mais sur la
base de l'obligation pour toutes et pour
tous la première partie donc c'est qu'un
fameux 15 jours c'est c'est eux qui
coûte de l'argent en plus et donc pas
grand chose
de cohésion enfin vous quand je parle
d'accrobranche en fait c'est à dire que
c'est ce qu'on connaît en entreprise on
va mettre les gens enfin du saut à
l'élastique ensemble ils vont être bon
ils vont s'amuser pendant 15 jours sur
le temps scolaire alors qu'on a déjà
tant de difficultés que le système
scolaire on va
franchement moi je préférerais que ce
soit pendant l'année scolaire toute
l'année que les cours d'instruction
civique soient renforcées je préférerais
que on est là plus enseignant qu'on
puisse perdre qu'on puisse recruter
grâce aux milliards
et là vous aurez peut-être l'encadrement
que ça plus efficace et qui sera
continue et non pas simplement pour
qu'un jour de balade je comprends bien
monsieur le député effectivement que
donc vous êtes contre le SNU ce beau
projet structurant mais obligatoire mais
est-ce que est-ce que je peux vous
croire en fait bah oui là est-ce que
vous n'êtes pas aujourd'hui
l'incohérence incarnée
quand je vois que vous avez voté la
réforme Touraine et que vous voulez
maintenant voter enfin vous avez voté
contre la la réforme des retraites quand
vous avez
défendu le 49-3 sous le gouvernement
Hollande et que maintenant vous le
combattez et vous voulez même le sortir
de la Constitution quand vous voulez
abroger la loi travail alors même que
vous l'avez voté en tant que député et
président de groupe lorsque vous avez
signé une tribune que j'aurais pu signer
avec vous sur la laïcité et que vous
défilez bras dessus bras dessous avec
ceux qui laissent à penser que ceux qui
ont vécu Charlie il avait peut-être bien
cherché ou ceux qui aujourd'hui
pardonnez-moi ou qui pardonnez-moi mais
qui disent que la laïcité est un vrai
problème c'est pas Grosso monsieur
je pense sincèrement que vous êtes un
cas vous êtes un cas vous êtes un cas
unique en France en fait vous êtes le
seul hollandais mélenchoniste bien sûr
alors d'abord on va essayer de pas se
traiter de nom d'oiseaux parce que si
apparemment c'est pas un gros mot pour
vous vous pourrez derrière votre
parcours et il n'y a pas de souci assez
édifiant donc j'en en parlerai même il
est très cohérent surtout contre vous
par ailleurs je vois pas du tout le
rapport que vous mettez entre ce que
j'ai pu voter avec la loi Touraine et ce
qu'est cette réforme aujourd'hui aucun
rapport la loi Touraine vous devez vous
en souvenir c'était une loi qui permette
en fait de protéger les carrières
longues qui permettait aussi de mettre
de faire en sorte qu'il y ait des gens
qui soient pour les métiers pénibles en
situation de partir plutôt ce qu'on a
fait et on a recréé des critères de
pénibilité à la demande d'ailleurs des
organisations syndicales
de
pénibilités
entre le
[Musique]
la prochaine fois et vous viendrez avec
une documentation en montrant ce que
j'ai fait pas fait etc en l'occurrence
et sur la laïcité j'ai pas changé d'avis
non plus donc vous avez signé un accord
aujourd'hui avec un parti politique qui
remet en cause et qui dit même que la
laïcité est un problème n'importe quoi
personne ne dit que la laïcité est un
problème
y compris pour Jean-Luc Mélenchon mais
quand vous étiez pas spécialiste vous
deviez vous en souvenir Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et on était aussi et il était
celui qui donnait des codes laïcité à
tout le monde donc bien sûr vous devriez
quand même avoir
et ce que je vous dis c'est que moi j'ai
une partage pas il y a des gens enfin
insoumises qui ont parfois eu des mots
que je connais je n'ai pas participé à
cette manifestation à laquelle vous
faites référence à laquelle participait
les communistes les écologistes et
beaucoup de monde en réalité est-ce que
ça en fait des gens qui sont contre la
laïcité non ça venait à la suite d'une
un attentat contre une mosquée et donc
eux avaient considéré que ça permet ça
devait passer par dessus tout le reste
moi j'ai conseillé de passer pas par
dessus tout le reste c'était une
appréciation différente mais ça ne fait
pas de ces gens là des anti républicains
comme vous avez tendance à vouloir
maintenant l'affirmer mais soyez
cohérent vous et continuez à vous battre
contre l'extrême droite parce que ce que
je vois que vous faites aujourd'hui si
vous êtes en train de dédiaboliser
l'extrême droite pour essayer de
diaboliser la gauche vous devriez avoir
honte tout seul monsieur le député
rappelez-vous juste que nous nous avons
appelé à voter pour les candidats du
Parti socialiste quand ils étaient
opposés au rassemblement national que
vous ne faites pas aujourd'hui avec
votre candidate dissidente qui est vous
vous préférez voter pour l'extrême
gauche celle qui est antivax celle qui a
eu des positions sur Israël qui sont
indignes de la gauche pardonnez-moi mais
il y a aussi un vrai sujet mais c'est
fou monsieur fort vous avez dit tout à
l'heure sur le plateau vous avez dit sur
le plateau que vous souteniez vous
souteniez effectivement la candidature
de l'année
c'est quand même essayons d'être là
aussi si vous voulez être dans la vérité
est-ce qu'elle est antivax elle est prof
de science et technologie elle est pour
la vaccination elle était contre le
passe sanitaire c'est pas tout à fait la
même chose c'est un problème de liberté
de le public où elle est non
sur la question de l'antisémitisme elle
est elle a été soutenir une proposition
de résolution du Parti communiste qui va
d'ailleurs être discussion prochainement
à l'Assemblée est-ce que les communistes
sont antisémites est-ce que ils ont
repris une accusation que vous pouvez ne
pas partager qui veut dire
Israël et je ne suis pas sûr aujourd'hui
mais est-ce que vous condamnez cette
proposition je pense que depuis tout à
l'heure vous parlez pardonnez-moi il y a
une question sur la sécurité vous avez
donné des propos
vous avez vous montrer des propos aucune
vous avez porté des accusations très
graves sur la police pardonnez-moi vous
avez une nouvelle doctrine vous voulez
pas qu'on vous aviez
un sujet à l'autre pour éviter qu'on
vous répond la nouvelle doctrine
d'Olivier spécialiste attention
attention on ne comprend plus rien
et j'espère que vous ne serez jamais
ministre de l'intérieur c'est de faire
en sorte que lorsqu'il y a des
manifestations il ne faut surtout pas
mettre de force de l'ordre c'est
exactement ce que vous avez dit et vous
avez porté des accusations très
complotistes pardonnez-moi sur le fait
même que le gouvernement était à
l'initiative du chaos que qui se sont
des qui se déroulent hier
effectivement ce sont des grands
accusations et et appréciation du fait
que ça pourrait être du complotisme de
dire que le gouvernement effectivement
préfère le chaos
révolutionner c'est la dernière que la
dernière révolutionnaire complotiste
anti vague antisémite etc bon c'est vous
qui vous aurez
tous vos élèves tous vos mots clés vous
êtes contents vous repartirez heureux et
j'espère que vous aurez un bon point
mais la réalité c'est que Monsieur fort
la démocratie
prise de position écoutez on va
s'arrêter là
alors je l'ai jamais été donné monsieur
yacobelli ça devient que vous dit merci
merci à tous les deux enfin merci si je
puis dire si je puis dire sur le fond
mais malheureusement c'est pas possible
pour soutenir nos forces de prochaine
fois réponds si vous voulez on a déjà vu
on a déjà eu ce débat de l'ordre je le
fais
Vincent roux pour une ultime question
d'actualité Vincent Vincent dernière
question très vite malheureusement
allez-y
Olivier fort est-ce que vous êtes
satisfait de la corde trouver entre
l'Allemagne et la Commission européenne
sur les véhicules thermiques l'Allemagne
accepte le passage donc en 2035 pour les
véhicules électriques à condition de
torique d'autoriser les coeurs de
synthèse pour les véhicules haut de
gamme est-ce que ça vous satisfait non
ça nous satisfait pas parce que vous
savez que tout ce qui est
if you etc c'est aussi un problème parce
que il produisent autant de NOx que les
carburants traditionnels et je vois bien
quel est l'intérêt de l'Allemagne
l'intérêt de l'Allemagne c'est d'avoir
ses 800 000 emplois dans l'automobile
c'est une industrie qui est très
puissante et aujourd'hui il cherche à
sauvegarder leurs propres industrie moi
je pense que ça se fait là au détriment
d'une transition qui doit se repérer
rapidement et pas en maintenant donc les
véhicules thermiques plus longtemps et
donc c'est une c'est une c'est un faux
bon accord voilà
vous avez votre réponse merci beaucoup
est-ce que vous êtes inquiet Olivier
fort parce que je vous demandais en
introduction où est la sortie à cette
crise elle avait une grande
manifestation vous dites le retrait
sinon rien pour l'instant le retrait de
la réforme le référendum la dissolution
en fait un moyen de purger la séquence
et de faire en sorte que soit le
président se rend compte enfin qu'il est
minoritaire et c'est très bien soit
parce qu'il ne veut pas s'en rendre
compte mais qu'il constate par les urnes
et à partir de là les choses seront
dites et le peuple souverain sur la sur
la réforme ou sur une autre question
et donc parce que je vois bien regardez
ce qui s'est passé avec Monsieur
yakovelli on voit bien que ils sont là
avec leurs éléments de langage précis de
renvoyer on est juste dans l'invective
et dans la disqualification de l'autre
l'autre est toujours en fait anti
républicain anti-toux etc et donc on
veut les diaboliser pour disqualifier
leurs paroles moi ce que je veux c'est
un débat de fond et ce débat de fond
nous l'avons eu assez largement pendant
la dernière semaine et malheureusement à
l'issue de ce débat de fond le président
n'a pas convaincu et donc il y a une
logique à ce que le retrait intervienne
maintenant voilà
participé à cette émission publique
merci à tous on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine à 19h30 sur LCP et public
Senna bonne soirée
[Musique]